they're Li 12 hours after last night's
visit Kate Middleton was on her way back
to Westminster Abbey with her
brother-in-law to be Prince Harry by her
side they weaved into the back entrance
of the historic venue eagerly the bride
entered first followed by Prince Harry
marching close behind him two
bridesmaids and a pageboy the
last-minute rehearsals have only served
to swell the crowds outside as the
excitement builds on the eve of the big
day there's strategy in where you sit
apparently there are so many
well-wishers have now arrived outside
Westminster Abbey to bag their prime
locations they've had to create a
one-way system for pedestrians and soon
it'll be camping room only it's an image
that will no doubt stick in the mind of
Kate Middleton as she departed her final
rehearsal waving as she did to those
who'll applaud her arrival come 11:00
a.m. tomorrow
what happens then is now much clearer
with the order of service released it
starts with a message from the couples
saying how delighted they are to be
joined by the congregation and how moves
they are by the affection they've been
shown the choice of music is very
personal to the couple but the first
hymn guide me o thou great Redeemer is
sung to the tune with Welsh connections
come rumba for a prince who is known as
William Wales and in her vows Catherine
Middleton like many other modern Brides
will not honor and obey her husband but
comfort and keep Prince William the
order of service
this is a British event there's music
from Wales and Scotland from all parts
of the United Kingdom and from further
afield where that been influenced is
brought in through the way in which they
wanted to celebrate themselves they
wanted a wedding that was similar to
their friends but at the same time
represented the state and while
rehearsals ease nerves for some for
Prince William a little sport with pals
just the tonic in his final days as a
single man the groom on Tuesday evening
arrived at Battersea Park on his Ducati
motorbike for a kick about with just
hours left before she marries Kate
Middleton arrived at the London hotel
where with her family she'll spend her
last night as a single woman she will
have said her goodbyes to Prince William
the next time they are together they
will become husband and wife